Oh [Music]
mover slow
sorry
[Music]
particle
[Music]
yeah be my
[Music]
that's all
[Music]
[Music]
boo bah
[Music]
[Music]
the
but at all
move all suave
salvadore
[Music]
but
[Music]
but at all
hello everyone and welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sake I'm very excited
to be talking about sound meditation and
Ayurveda we have Serena Malkani joining
us on the show ice cream
how thank you so much for coming on our
show I really appreciate it thank you
for having me so grateful and blessed to
have you and what an incredible first
song that was there are so many
interesting vibes that come up for me
during that in a sense you're like this
Genie that's kind of guiding me through
this mystical spiritual connection that
I'm experiencing and it just it takes me
back to in time and I love feeling that
and I'm just we have so much fun packed
talking about the different sound
meditation this catalogue that you have
in the way that you can like combine
things and you know how you understand
sound and how it's healing and I read
and how that plays into this I'm so
excited for our conversation
those are doing Austria's background
she's a sound meditation leader and
Ayurvedic practitioner who helps people
unleash their potential through energy
music and vibrations you find our
website Serena Malkani calm as well as
your Instagram and YouTube pages highly
recommend checking those out watch some
of those YouTube videos you have some
great animations all
along with these on the YouTube side I
love it Thank You Serena let's start
things off with asking you what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
oh so the first thing that comes to my
mind when you say what are the thoughts
on the direction of the world are two
things one is that we are experiencing
sensory overload there's so much
information coming at us at all times
technology bridges the communication gap
but also makes it easy to know the dark
parts of what's happening and I think as
a society at least in America were
trained to produce produce produce and
also focus on the negative and the
fixing and it's so funny that you said
that my opening invocation and mantra
the Gayatri mantra which is the mother
of all mantras brought you back to an
feeling of ancient time because that's
where I think we need to go is back to
our ancient roots the people that
existed before all of this technology
and all these different ways of
communicating came about and learn from
them and learn from how they did
ritualistic things to heal themselves
and not necessarily healing in the sense
that there's a connotation that
someone's sick but to keep them in tune
and in vibration and able to you know
function at that level of society how
can we take some of those ancient
practices and modernize them to today so
that there's a way to implement these
tools and help people Center and relax
and ground especially in societies where
we're driven to work and produce I may
think America specifically has a lot of
a lot of emphasis on that
yeah I know the second largest economy
in the world China which assumed me to
be the first doing the same thing with
their productivity with their humans
that are there and there's four times as
many humans there that are doing the
hyper productivity which is that many
more of these like you explained there's
like tuning each human as a tuning fork
or it's being over stimulated by sensory
overload whereas like indigenous people
are walking around just like ding with
nature all the time every breath every
bite of food every connection to trees
animals all that is and there's this
intentional presence that I think we
lack one of my favorite teachers told me
that the other day working on my own
growth as a as a sound meditation
facilitator and someone who's offering a
message is what kind of intentional
presence do we have on a daily basis and
how much of our day is on autopilot you
know how much of what we're doing on a
daily basis is just you know known
activity to our body to our brain that
we're just producing and going through a
certain cycle and how much of it is this
intentional being and understanding that
there's elements of nature all around us
and how we can talk to those elements
from our body and relate to that and use
that to guide us as well you know we'll
be talking more about that with
Ayurvedic practices as well this is just
an array of instruments that do tuning
Wow in that most raw form of alignment
and I'm also excited to talk to you
about you know let's actually jump into
that I want to know about it how did you
pick up your interest in sound
meditation Ayurvedic practice but like
specifically people come come in and
they're like oh I have a
guitar whatever and you're like Elm this
is called a Shruti bomb like what is
that where does that come from how does
one even find that instrument and yeah
so first of its event singing bulls
which people are a little bit more it's
more popular definitely so the surety
boxes introduced to me by sylveon Akash
one of my sound meditation teachers and
it was actually originally played by the
foot and that's an ancient Indian
instrument and you know you could have
like a one-man show somebody playing a
sitar or another instrument percussion
instrument and they would be folding the
shruthi box with their foot to be able
to make this drone and sometimes you see
these out and being played with people
who are actually giving a presentation
or a talk about something important and
the reason why is because the effective
quality of the shruthi box is to help
the brain go through a process called
entrainment which essentially means that
your brainwave patterns are essentially
trying to come together and form an
equilibrium the consonants versus a
dissonance exactly and once that happens
you're able to relax the the human brain
relaxes into it your ears open you begin
to you know essentially tune yourself
through having these drone long-form
drone tones come into your body and then
you can actually access and learn and
process what someone is saying a little
bit better so this is meant to induce in
sound we call it the relaxation response
in the human body which is what all of
these instruments are aimed to do as
well as when you're using your own voice
to open and tune yourself so there's a
way to receive sound and also emit sound
and there's a lot of energy that happens
when you're actually making noise
and sealing yourself with sound and from
a physical and health perspective stress
is the number one cause of disease in
the human body it's all correlated so if
you're mentally stressed out about
something but is more than likely gonna
manifest physically in your body and so
if we can use sound which is the
backdrop of everything everything is a
sound including us everything that
exists makes some kind of noise and we
are talking through our frequencies
right now so sound is everywhere and
it's in our existence then we can use it
as a way to tune ourselves it's kind of
like you know just almost common sense
right when we listen to a song that has
an emotive quality like an Adele
you know she generally is talking about
a breakup or something like that and
there's the sadness but when we listen
to that we feel that so deeply and our
body our brain everything goes into that
mode similar to when we're going you
know dancing and we're listening to some
EDM and out and you know enjoying that
vibration with other people and wanting
to be pulled up into a different kind of
energy we're always using sound as
humans to affect our daily function and
how our brain is actually processing
things yet this idea that I can drone
with an instrument so I can repeat this
was it was it a G well we were playing
was a D it was a D ok so that I can
drone this D over and over again and
this is kind of similar to like an
accordion yeah it's like a portable a
little bit more portable harmonium or
accordion yeah it is set to the Eastern
scale instead of the Western scale so
for musicians out there the Eastern
scale means that the the note a is
equivalent to 432 Hertz instead of 440
so it's a different effective quality
that's happening and the way we hear the
music is different as well
more spiritual and crying they say that
there's you know the eastern scale
generally has that you know kind of
theme of being a little bit more
spiritual and the type of music that's
that's offered and rendered and you know
there's controversy over it so they
won't go too much into it almost as
though the the wess recent development
and it's even down to things like the
music being less spiritual have made it
so able to focus on just hyper
productivity building the tech building
the science building the singularity etc
etc right and the 5g right and ya know
longitudinal testing but don't worry
about that yeah it's like there's an
electromagnetic field of energy that's
always surrounding us right and these
these instruments help tune the field
around you yes and that means that when
we're pulling from that electromagnetic
field that's surrounding us we're also
inviting a certain vibration into our
bodies and again this like what I was
talking about with sensory overload
that's creating a sensation okay
so we can drone ourselves into
consonants so that's something that we
can do so
yeah weary and I have gotten obsessed
with using a xylophone oh yeah right now
it's just fun to be able to just play
with it and then feel it and then also
sing with it so that was the other
component is so you can get into a
droned state of consonants let the music
- knew that vibration frequency energy
tune you and
and you can then practice and this part
is something that I know a lot of people
struggle with it's kind of like also
your first appearance is on video or
first time playing a sport that you
don't know first time singing right
we're playing this for me you don't know
it's so important to just try Rea and
Trust and I think a lot of people have
you know blockages or just fears around
opening their voice and singing because
we're always taught oh you have to sing
a certain tune or this is off tune or
this is a tone and really it's about
making noise and creating a vibration
with your body right so when we sing
even if it's an AA or a silent hum to
yourself you're actually vibrating over
246 bones
going down through your body so imagine
what that's doing to you from a
bone-density perspective yeah what's
happening to your body how is your blood
moving how are your organs listening to
that all of those things right so in the
classic oh I do that you can feel it you
can feel it go through your body and if
you intentionally sing them and you know
you imagine it moving through your body
and again with that intentional presence
you can literally feel that ohm go
through and let's do that okay let's do
it yeah no let's do everyone please join
us yeah join us in a collective ohm
Oh
Oh
Oh
[Applause]
and if you noticed you know when we were
doing that our vibrations naturally
tried to match each other and come into
harmony just yeah the ohm the sound in
general just has me feeling you know
completely differently than normal and
that's so nice and to be able to
recreate that for ourselves these these
feelings of this is like one of our best
friends so this is one of our best
friends it's been around with us for
ever it we don't exist without sound
you know our frequency is the way we're
connecting with each other and
communicating and also we have this
inner silent voice like if you were
right now
to close your eyes and say hello to
yourself you could literally hear a
voice and close your eyes yeah that's
right say hello say it in all kinds of
funny ways hello hello hello
you can literally hear yourself of
there's a voice and no one else can hear
that exactly so interesting and we're
not actually emitting a sound but we're
creating a thought which has its own
signature as well right and every
thought has a vibration to it negative
or positive right and also we're sitting
with that that same voice that's saying
hello that we can control to do that
we're sitting with that little voice
that's talking to us at all times right
and sometimes we're in in a place where
if we're anxious or nervous that little
voice can guide us to maybe making
decisions based on that anxiety or on
those nerves versus being in this
centered this is my voice I'm gonna
listen to it
I can feel into it and I can I'm tuned
up to know that this is the right
decision or the right thing to say
etc etc and that comes from from two
things being in tune and vibration and
deep listening and sound can be these
these forms of meditation can be used to
deeply listen to yourself and that
quality of meditation then creates a
vibration in you that's emitted out and
then what what does that do from a
ripple effect if we're all walking
around in tune and being aware and
conscious of the decisions and things
were saying and feeling open to do so
yeah having more transformed
consciousness as as tuning forks walking
around cascading butterfly effects let's
get into continue on this journey yeah
yes okay so take us on how you got
started with this how did I get started
so I've always loved music and I used to
sing at the top of the mark in San
Francisco I used to sing standard jazz
songs while I was studying in graduate
school and something felt really empty
in me and I was going through a rough
time as a lot of San Francisco's no San
Francisco knows it's the you know hub of
all these startups and technology and
the startup I was working for at the
time that I found sound meditation
unfortunately decided to close and I was
left in Hayes Valley with a very
expensive rent to pay and not really
sure what I was going to do next
and my cat my friend was watching my cat
and unfortunately my cat got lost there
was all these things that happen that
we're just really like emotional hard
for me to handle all at once
and I started researching sound and
researching music healing sound therapy
all these different keywords in Google
and I found this school and this teacher
Sylvia who was referencing earlier who
teaches a class on sound voice and music
healing and it's taught at I I don't
think it's any longer there but it was
at the California Institute of integral
studies for many many years and I think
she's gone on now to have her own school
and you know she's taken her services to
Asia and all different places but that's
where I found it and it was really
beautiful to experience all these
different cultures through sound and
what I got from that was that even
though there was different ways of
making music they all had the same
quality which was to help humans relax
and express and be and you know that was
so profound to me to find a way to sing
again and use music in an embodied way
to offer a message to people and show
them that they can use this as a tool
anytime they want by themselves and the
science behind that is is so beautiful
so we we wake up in the morning and
we're in this active beta state which is
almost like I was saying that autopilot
you know you know you're gonna go get up
that get that coffee go to the bathroom
you know your commute excetera time to
pause and just enjoy the several minutes
of just beautiful morning without the
autopilot yeah kind of like there's so
many things that point towards you being
able to achieve your North Star more
effectively if you spend your morning
and evening before bed and
you wake up just envisioning what your
North Star is and what your path is to
get there and just taking deep breaths
being grateful stretching a bit you know
having that morning practice yes but
when we make a consistent vibration with
sound even if it's just a hum doesn't
have to be a beautiful singing thing or
anything yeah twenty-one minutes of
consistent sound will begin to
completely downshift that beta brainwave
pattern that beta state that we wake up
in the morning down to theta and theta
happens naturally the theta brainwave
pattern and cycle happens naturally when
we're in the last couple hours of our
sleep cycle where that kind of dream
half half awake half asleep state that's
our theta theta brainwave pattern state
so sound has that same quality if we do
it consistently and so even if you do it
in three and a half minute chunks of
humming to yourself and not even having
to have this expressive outward singing
or anything
you're beginning to number one tune
yourself vibrate all your bones which
there's a marma point of energy that's
then being delivered down marma is
related to Ayurveda and you're you're
essentially massaging your whole body
with vibration so that's why it's so
important for people to also let out
sound you know these days the sound
meditation or getting a sound bath with
some of these tools like like you were
saying they're more common it's almost
like getting a massage you know it's
it's known but what's really important
and you know why even coming on the show
is important for me today was to tell
people to make sound yes to emit energy
that way too and then seal yourself up
with a sound bath play with your voice
feel your frequency because when you do
that then you'll be able to hear your
own inner voice that skill of deeply
listening not only to yourself but other
people and the vibrations around you
becomes more clear
your journey with what led you here is
sometimes these are our tests of faith
along our path and to see you know what
were the bifurcating moments that led
you to discover your own passion for
searching for music and for testing your
own musical abilities and for playing
around with different instruments and
and then like you explained you know
coming here onto the show and enriching
us with your enthusiasm for sound and
helping other people
tap deeper into their own relationships
with instruments it should be law every
human should have one instrument in
their home I kind of percent agree let's
have one instrument in your home you get
to pick which one really you must have
yeah and and then the more that we then
tap into it and and play it and when we
can we carrier on an instrument with us
all the time our voice yeah and so then
to be able to work at that and build
that skill up you know level up this
skill that's with us all the time yeah
yeah it's with you forever
and tell you you know maybe I don't know
beyond but it's with you forever and I
think to your point how I got involved
in this is through my own darkness right
and we all have dark and light to us
everyone goes through it that's part of
being human and it's okay
and what this sound did and what Sylvia
my teacher helped me understand was how
to use my dark and transmute it and make
light even if it was really hard to do
that and I'm really really grateful
because now when I sing even a jazz song
which I still love to do I feel more
embodied with it and it just feels
different to me now
and so I love that I love that I found a
way to feel really full with music and
that idea of performance is no longer
part of my vocabulary it's about an
offering and it's about an invitation to
play with your own voice for me yeah
yeah to have more people feel like
they're being invited to play with their
voice out in our world is massively
important
okay so then walk us through then how
you ended up picking out the different
instruments how you ended up taking
people through the processes of sound
meditation what that's even like yeah so
the instruments came as I deepened my
practice the first one was the shruti
box shruthi means two things note in
Sanskrit and also truth and yeah and it
helps it's a drone right so when you
listen to it that and Trainmen process
is occurring and that allows me to then
make vibration with my voice and let it
take me to wherever and just be free and
express whatever's coming from whatever
channel whatever it might be and then I
started leading meditations with people
with just the sure--they box and helping
them and I'd love to do a little sample
with you okay yeah let's do it if you
want so we do now okay let's do it I did
bring you your own little shrieky box
who brought me uh um you call this a
mini 30 box
yeah it's just a mini version that same
it has the same notes but you can it
carry it around a little ease more
easily this is actually
yeah this is actually an octave so is
essentially c2c okay as if you were
playing a piano these are the sharps
okay the same thing on this one C two C
sharps cool these are just more densely
packed together yeah and it's just a
smaller like you'll have to play that a
little bit more quickly and you need to
keep the rhythm and this one is a little
bit you know it sustains the note a
little bit the valium and how big it is
I feel like your younger brother I am
learning right now so before we even
open to the shruthi box what I want to
do is just kind of set us in to how we
can get ready to to play with our voice
okay so we're gonna do a little bit of
I'm gonna put this down for a second
okay I'm gonna do a little bit of
alternate nostril pranayama breathing to
get ourselves into a place to to make
noise and be in the sound alternative
alternate nostril alternate nostril
breathing or pranayama yeah okay which
will just kind of help balance our
energy so what I want you to do is plug
one join us ever yes please join us yeah
okay
plug one flat plug one nostril and then
take a deep inhale on the other one and
then plug both I'd hold your breath hold
hold hold but push out the other side
yeah just let it go take your time
perfect
now when all the others never breed like
that before in one hold out the other
dozen that out of all the meditative
practices never that one see there's so
many Rea there's so many ways to get
there so keep this other nostril closed
okay and then now when that's empty take
a deep breath on this side and plug hold
hold hold hold
push out the other side beautiful one
more time deep inhale on this side and
plug hole hole push up
now go ahead and use the full power of
your nose take a deep breath and I want
you to release on a snake-like sounds
beautiful one more time feel your belly
expand and
one last time feel your belly fill with
air and release
on your next inhale what I'd like you to
do is meet that snake-like sound with
your voice and let any sound come out so
take a deep inhale and let your voice
meet your breath it doesn't matter what
comes out to be pretty
[Music]
can be anything that's part of being
free and feeling free yes and then we
could take the Shruthi okay Josh is part
of being free not being constrained to
what seems to be a cult a cultural norm
that actually why is it that so few
people are seeing while they're on the
streets why so few people are just you
know at play like you know just making
fun noses with their voices and dancing
with their bodies and maybe their
beatboxing and doing some lyrics over it
you know all these different options so
few people are doing it or told not to
gray or told ya and I'm kind of maybe
I'm a little bit worried I'm not sure if
I understood him correctly or not
there's this guy Matt at the Chinese
consulate today and he was thought he's
lived in the Beijing for like 11 years
and he was just telling me in two
separate locations but he was just
telling me that people are very careful
about social norms and to not you know
they're very socially aware they don't
want to affect other people's you know
ambience and energy and I'm like we're
trying to understand that and you know
embody it and realize it at the same
time it's like I kind of don't want to
walk around a bunch of other people that
are not expressing themselves I want to
I want like people to be on the streets
expressing themselves to whatever
creative degree they want to be and for
me to be like wow look at all these cool
creative people maybe that's just some
fantasy world that
but I would personally love to see that
too you know but I think that there's a
container that we can create and how
people take the steps to being able to
do that for themselves at anytime right
not just in the shower yes when your
voice always sounds good yeah so like
being able to just say this is my time
to listen to one of these instruments
and just mess around and there's no
wrong or right there's no pretty or off
tone or on tone it's just about
vibrating yes which is why we were so
cool about just being like we can have a
conversation right now just with sound
we didn't even have to talk and we have
an energy being exchanged don't worry
and I worry when I spend like two hours
or something like that with one of our
friends in the old neighbor just like
laying on this carpet in the studio and
just making noises and just transforming
our consciousness together in a
completely sober state just enjoying the
whatever came through us energetically
musically through the sound and it was
all different types of audio didn't
matter a gorgeous it was like play it
felt like a child I felt innocent and
pure and and I felt so far away from the
economic machinery of productive
civilization right but then I realized
that everything that I did and made me
way more productive afterward because
now I have more of
now I have more of a true I think
spiritual grounding in childhood or more
of a spiritual grounding and play and
yeah right and that that makes you more
authentic right to yourself and it makes
you aware even if you're not expressing
in the streets and going wild there's
something centered about you because
you've given yourself that permission to
do it yeah and you know that we using
sound like this is like exercising for
an hour it really is what it's doing
from a scientific perspective to your
brain and how do we all feel when we go
to that like amazing yoga class or just
like great swimming running around the
track nice night of sleep theory this
can do it same way just again like that
that idea that one meditation might not
work for someone but it could be the
saving grace for someone else
yeah you know yeah and the different
just like a different instrument it's
like different instruments to it certain
things talk to you yeah oh my gosh okay
so now we take what we learned with the
bad Hey and now I'll try to depending on
you know how open the person is feeling
try to make some noise together with
them so what I'm gonna walk you through
which everyone can do together in a good
way it's a tool that you can take for
yourself and do it anytime is the
Tibetan warrior seed syllables so this
meditation came pre Buddhism
pre-buddhist times and there's five main
energy centers that they focused on each
having a certain ancient sound to them
and we're gonna go through each one and
just sound it out together so if you
could put your shruthi box on the second
node yes perfect you got it and which
one or what was this again good dee dee
dee
we're gonna make some noise together at
432 432 Hertz
that's something new matches her
[Music]
the first feed syllable is accessing the
crown and above the crown energy energy
that's coming
through this area sir die and it's
simply ah so I want you to close your
eyes everyone close their eyes and
imagine a white light coming down
through your body as we sing ah together
take a deep breath
feel free to go at your own pace when it
comes out
[Music]
ah
or do it three more times
ah
on this next one I want you to let out
all the stress you've been feeling in
the day really let it out
pretty hot
laughs one
ah
go ahead and take a deep inhale
and again we'll just clear the palate
with that snake-like sounds
[Music]
[Music]
one more breath just like that
and one last one
I'm gonna walk you through to the the
next seed syllable which is for our
throat Center
area right here a way we express and
communicate received
and
syllable for that is simply own but
saving rooms so if you're gonna chant
ohm chant the oh and the end because the
O and the M actually represent the union
of the feminine and the masculine in our
bodies and the color associated with
this this energy center is a beautiful
blue
so as we do this I want you to imagine a
blue light coming in you and also
emitting out of you will do only
together okay and the blue lights also
coming from
[Music]
from here so just kind of like emanating
from
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
and let it all out your best own
Oh
ah
last one
Oh
go ahead and clear the pallet the snakes
out
[Music]
[Music]
this next one is my favorite one we can
play with it a lot and it's the heart
center
the seed syllable for the heart center
is pond and it spells hu ng with an over
pronounced H as if you're you know
letting out energy through that H and
since the heart beads that you know
different times and different speeds we
can take this fast and slow and still
have that same effect and the color that
I want you to think about an associate
with this is a beautiful emerald green
coming in and out of your heart center
hum-hum
yeah
[Music]
now huh
fun
huh
[Music]
how long
[Music]
Hong Kong Hong Kong Hong Kong Hong Kong
Hong Kong
[Music]
three more huh ha
hi
[Music]
and again we'll do that snake-like sound
so the fourth out of the five syllables
is activating our solar plexus and
sacral chakra
the syllable is wrong
wrong wrong
and I want you to imagine like a orange
and yellow swirly soup
swirling inside of your chakras here the
two that connects up here
as you sing wrong sing wrong
and orange and yellow a light of soup
raaah
ah
[Music]
raaah
with your next ROM I want you to ask the
universe for something Colin something
[Music]
[Music]
ah
two more rah
[Applause]
ah
deep breath
[Music]
so the last seed syllable represents our
root chakra and our ability to feel
grounded and centered
and that seed syllable is za and it's
spelled d VA pronounced ha
and the color associated with saw is a
beautiful red crimson red
and imagine the earth supporting you
beautiful red light shining through you
[Music]
ah
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
I really let it out it doesn't have to
be prettier on tone
Oh
three more Zaza
ah
ah
[Music]
take a deep breath
[Music]
I'm gonna stay right there
sit with that for a minute
I'd love to hear how you feel right now
felling vibration
I felt less physical felt more like
vibration
I felt like my vocal cords were like
whoa that's a lot that you're putting
onto us
all right this is more often excitement
with activations in different parts of
the body aligned with different sounds
that we make and
do you feel any sort of like routing or
centering or calmness
yeah lots of routing lots of calmness
lots of centering yeah yeah was where
it's all correct yeah
oh wow and the beauty of like a tool
like this the bond meditation is that
you don't need even an instrument to do
it right we used a drone but really if
you were at home and just wanted to play
you could do this without anything just
your voice
yeah
yeah with just your voice you can play
this I was also
I was realizing how much even just how
much work it is box and to remember you
know over at the esses in between the
being able to alter the home or
whichever one you're on and that was
actually taking quite a bit of yeah
coordination coordination that's it was
totally transformative totally
transformative and that was only a
couple minutes and and these tuning
forks are I think we were we were
talking about how we want people to be
individual tuning forks walking around
completely tuned and there's a wonderful
book called human tuning by John value
if you want to learn more about the
affect of tuning forks and what they're
doing to the brain I don't feel that I'm
an expert on these but I know that they
have an effective energetic quality and
so I use them and carry them with me and
you just lean against each other's very
gently
and play it into the mic a little bit
and if you listen very closely if I
bring them close to your ear you hear
that vibration mm yeah so your ear and
your electromagnetic field is being
tuned to this vibration picking up this
side did that new sound come from them
interlock
oh yeah
and then
we have all the seeing bowls as well as
the Japanese Hoshi chime yeah so we've
got some so yeah you can and you can
also play these are what's great about
the the chimes is that you know they're
intuitive you don't need to know how to
play anything really yeah please just
can see whatever comes out feel
any kind of spontaneous such serious
[ __ ] was happening earlier to even on
before the show
Zack Lee trust what's coming out
[Music]
[Music]
so it's beautiful about these chimes is
that their cords that are meant to
represent the elements earth air fire
water and ether there's a little it's a
little like marbled piece those that
can't see this when and if you're
listening gentlemen listening to it
there's this co sheet
chime is a wooden cylinder that's
hollowed out that has one two four five
six seven eight
eight different sized thin metal
cylinders poking out from it and then in
the center is a chime like a rope that's
coming down that has a little like
marble piece on it so when you move it
that little marble piece hits the
different sized chimes just create the
different notes
that's a scale to both the scale those
are all scale up just like
wow this is another one of those that
gave me chills playing oh that's another
big lesson I haven't been doing that but
I should do that actually missed a few
bucks but you actually show me a bit of
the tuning fork but that's another
important lesson is when he'd play
instrument don't just play here but play
it it sounds completely different
absolutely you like can you're way more
of the vibration of the actual body of
this whereas before here's so far away
this is a very very cool instrument I
can see how it's easy to become an
instrument addict yeah and that's part
of you know part of the the sound
meditation so back to your question
about how I got all these instruments
was I realized that there is something
about helping to seal that energy
vibration we created through using our
voice with these instruments as well
that helps kind of tune the whole body
so you're emitting and receiving the
same type of Eastern scale going out and
so as you as many people know the
singing bowls this is a chord it's a
seeing a G so root chakra and your
throat chakra that's what I brought
today so this is the root chakra the C
[Music]
if we want to bring us into harmony it's
kinda like the birth of the universe
worth all crash
leave them together
see how loud we can go
you can see it has that quality of
helping you relax helping you just sink
into your body yeah you're you're
transforming my consciousness when you
play that I am going deeper into a scene
when when those are both on it's just
making me feel like I can melt into all
that is and just be that and like I'm
just like oh my gosh this is so much to
handle I gotta do this because then you
can have music trigger that that
beautiful dive into unbounded wholeness
and love and then what but then all of
the industries all the the fake
industries collapse that are preaching
you need exogenously found outside of
you for happiness and for love and for
let's stuff all those industries die
that's why there's been a silencing of
this for the longest time especially in
the hyper productive West and your your
words are bringing up a thought that I
think is really important has as a
planet right now we're going through
monumental shift and the answer is to go
with in truly believe that the answer is
that if everyone becomes the highest
version of themselves and goes inward
instead of outward like you were saying
yeah then we will produce the society we
want to live in together but the answer
is not outside like you said it's inside
how do you go inside some people have
like you know incredible ability to be
silent and sit still and meditate and
you know home their practice that way
some people can use sound right there's
so many different types of meditations
so many different ways to access that
version of yourself that we've all felt
in different ways and no it's there but
how do we keep that constant and it's
about doing the daily work that gets you
there whether that's running on the
Embarcadero or doing a yoga class or
working with sound what is it that you
do on a daily basis that gets you into
your authentic route and place of
expression where you're truly yourself
that's really hard especially with
everything we have all the sensory oh
how do you identify who know thyself and
how do you identify how to quickly get
in that mode where you're in that mode
of I you've identified what it is you're
pursuing it you're actively finding
meaning in that moment to moment
Serena we've looked over a good amount
of the individual stuff we've been
explaining this quite a bit like this is
very important to do to get an
instrument and to play it on a daily
basis let it tune you do this sound
meditation more often and share with
other people that's huge now I want to
ask about how does this work for also
for healing purposes for all of the
finding treasures on the other side of
trauma so that integration process how
does it work for that how does it work
for when this happens in the setting of
like 10 people at a time or 20 people at
a time like all of us like you and I
were just going back and forth well then
org comes up as well and then then all
of a sudden you know another person
comes up and we have like five people
playing different things how do those
synergize you know or if all five of us
are laying in one person is doing the
orchestrating
there's all these different wasted
there's so many layers right so when we
come together we're making a collective
vibration that's sending out a ripple
effect right and there's been studies
about this not necessarily with sound
but with a group of people meditating
large groups of people meditating and
how that activates other people to go
into that transformative state and start
meditating themselves yes so what we're
doing is invoking that through the sound
we're asking for that collective
vibration to be created a collective
energy that then is going outwards and
we're sharing that through our frequency
which is the most important thing that
we have as humans that identifies us is
our voice and yet if you think about it
in so many ways you know I think as a
woman or a man you're stifled in
different environments whether it's a
you know relationship you don't feel
good in or it's you know work dynamic
where you don't feel like you're
expressing yourself or whether it's you
just muting yourself and letting that
inner voice be so critical that you
aren't able to offer who you are to even
yourself right there's so many ways that
our voice becomes this stifling factor
and doing this type of work will help
you release that and there's a lot of
traumas that people carry and I've been
really excited to work with some plant
medicine specifically held in a very
safe container there's a center called
Polaris insight Center and it's a group
of psychotherapists they're all Maps
trained so they've been doing the
research they're part of this research
program that's been ongoing on using
plant medicines and different types of
of ways to help heal trauma through that
and what's been really cool is that I've
gotten to offer sound meditations and
voice opening sessions to these
therapists that are doing that and
that's been trickling down into me being
able to be part of their Center and also
offer it to their clients and it's
profound what a plant medicine can do in
conjunction with sound and the effect
that you can have feeling completely
uninhibited of in your body and being
like you said just away from your your
mental state and your physical state but
really just being that happens even more
pronounced with these plant medicines
and so I'm really excited that that's
something that's continuing to go on and
people more and more people more and
more therapists are using sound as a
modality to help people with their
traumas and and clear out those energies
that no longer serve them so yeah yeah
really cool yeah clear out the energies
and no longer serve us right process of
clearing and just healing and
integrating letting it go and leveling
up right and making peace with it right
so many times when you're in an altered
state of consciousness and we think
about something that's happened we think
about it in a different way and so
that's what sound is helping you do as
well it's helping you make a new
relation to the specific event or thing
we're feeling that you've been carrying
with you and
you know we we do a one by one by one
and that makes a collective effect and
then we can do it also with groups where
we're each taking on different
instruments or one person's
orchestrating the sound meditation for
everyone
interesting and there's different
instruments from around the world to be
able to yeah pick weave you have a
little um kalimba yeah those are so fun
and so relaxing it gives you a physical
focus as well right so you're doing
something that's meditative with your
hands as well and there's so much right
that you can do in conjunction with
sound the mudras you know how we hold
our hands and we meditate these all
activate certain energy points in our
bodies
so and you can feel that if you actually
play with your fingers yes and breathe
there's a different effect of where that
breath is going and how it's coming into
you
so we're so powerful we're literally
superhuman we are we just we are and
these are all things that came from
where buried buried bury did not express
the economic machineries like you need a
job and you need to make money to pay
for your runs in your food you got it
yeah I think it's beautiful I will say
that there's more and more schools that
are teaching meditation right so we're
seeing younger kid like kids at a
younger age get involved in these things
and I'm so happy to see that so it's not
all you know bad but you know the is the
suppression of that beautiful expression
of everyone's creative potential is that
suppression being done by malevolent
forces and are there like uh nevolin
forces that are at play to compete at
them on this chess game of Earth does
that is that what it feels like I mean I
think so it's dark and light right at
its highest and we are we have the
ability as humans to let our inner
demons control us and act in the dark
right so when you think about it from
not even forces outside of us we become
a force so we can be that dark person
and we can be that light person and we
can choose which way we want to be at
all times
really and what has been one of your
keys for making a choice in the positive
direction like I don't think anyone's
perfect at that yeah but yeah right we
all have it been you know if I do go
into that dark space I think it's a
point of introspection of why I went
there and then also specifically I know
that sound
brings me up I know that when I sing I'm
not aware of anything else besides
that emotional quality of what I'm
releasing and that helps me and so I
found this as a tool that I want to
share to other people who might enjoy
music in general and can use this as a
way to Center themselves and help their
daily lives become better and stay in
the light because it's really about that
consistency of the little things that
add up we're just all about Ayurveda to
see of light consistency of light yes
and that comes from the details of your
daily habits your your daily thoughts
how you start and end your days we were
talking about that morning practice
being important right it's like llq is
both love quotient and light quotient
yeah I like that yeah really though love
quotient and light quotient and that's
like on a moment-to-moment basis it's a
with that free will a quick question
before I revert or is this one big
artistic expression of creation I think
everything in life is an experiment and
tell you everything that you would do
even this this whole thing right now we
haven't planned this this show we didn't
don't really know what's coming out it's
all an experiment right cooking in the
kitchen and you could play it on a
crystal - I've seen that done but Jen
and then I also have those weighted ones
that play on the bodies that's sending a
vibration into your body really is gonna
be a 12 hour show or you can you handle
it we can wrap up soon if we need to of
course this is just like such pure
passions it's gone on obviously so so
these are directed to you yeah he's a
director tune of course this is a third
eye for the third eye and again and you
know human tuning that book has a lot of
information about tuning forks there's
really a lot of science here wish I
could explain that I
I don't feel first enough to do that but
you can hit this on I usually have a
rubber stopper but we'll use the mallet
and you can hear a low vibration in the
ear yeah there's a very low vibration
that is gonna actually be played this
weight this rubber take a deep breath
just release
so you should be able to feel this go
through your entire body if you can
imagine there's you're lying on a table
and you have these Forks and someone's
playing them on you what its gonna do is
relax you completely and what that's
gonna do is help you not be stressed and
that's what that's what's going to
prevent you from getting sick feel like
that's massive and it just feels like
that wisdom is so evidently visible in
ancient civilizations before us there
were so many of these vibrational
knowledge --is that were being used to
like levitate and and all these other
how could you how could you direct these
frequencies at a central point and then
levitate an object and like what would
happen to a human in that point would
like completely feel like God feel
healed fuel yeah like unbounded love you
know it's just we totally are like lost
running around in these metropolis
versus actually experiencing those
healing and meditative modalities and
you bring up a good point look in the
ancient times there was a community
around this type of healing
it happened together we made vibrations
together and I think that element of
community is so important to enforce is
doing the things that make you feel
better together yeah going you know it
you could do a yoga practice on your own
any time right you don't need to go to a
class but what happens when you go to a
class and you're with a group of people
you're creating a collective community a
collective vibration together so it's so
important to make noise with people yes
yes so important yes man even from the
very first granson
from the very first Brownson even from
the very first organisms that emitted
sound to be able to communicate and make
decisions in the in evolute in the path
of evolution let's do a a bit on
Ayurvedic practice as well yeah so I our
Veda for those of you don't know is a
very ancient Indian science and it's
based on the the five elements earth air
fire water and ether and how us as
humans that are taking those elements
into our bodies through our five senses
and so earlier when I was talking about
sensory overload Ayurvedic practice and
a science in which the whole goal is to
clear the senses called panchakarma
clearing of the five senses and what's
so unique about Ayurveda is that
everyone has their own dosha or dominant
energy that's made up of these elements
and there's three main doshas and you
could we are all of them but there's
generally one that's more dominant one
or two they're more dominant in your
personal Constitution the way you were
made and so those energies are Vata
Pitta and kapha and Vata is like an air
energy it's made up of ether and air so
when you think about Vata and how that
manifests in the human body it's someone
who's in balance
is bubbly and creative and full of life
and is starting many things kind of like
a social butterfly you know that kind of
energy and you know they're they're just
full of ideas and full of vibration but
someone who's out of balance what air
energy can do is actually make someone
nervous and anxious and maybe nail
biting and starting a bunch of things
but never really getting to finish them
and they're just kind of all over the
place and lost and they have too many
thoughts in their head so that's kind of
what imbalance and out of balance mean
and the second energy is is a Pippo
which is our intensity our fire energy
it's our fire and water energy and pipa
people are generally like the people
that have the to-do lists you know like
they're they need to cross everything
off and they're always they always have
a plan
they're super passionate and they're you
know ready to they're often leaders and
they're ready to take on the world and
you know make change but out of balance
a hit the personality or pitta dosha
would be someone who's like angry and
like overly judgmental of themselves and
other people and very self-critical and
too fiery too sharp with the tongue you
know not even realizing it that they're
jabbing or kind of being you know caddy
for lack of better words and the last
energy the kapha energy is the water and
earth energy and these people are
generally very grounded and you know
very nurturing very caring they have all
the emotional qualities of sensitivity
all of that wrapped up into their energy
and at the same time if they're not in
balance then they're overly sensitive
and they don't want to make any kind of
change any kind of change for them is
too hard they're very set in their ways
and they're not sure you know how to
move from one place or phase of life to
the other and that can be you know hard
because you feel like you're stuck in
the mud and so the goal of Ayurveda is
to understand how we intake information
through the five senses and so I know
that we're running kind of late on time
but I would say that I would ask this
from an Ayurvedic perspective what are
you ingesting not just in the way you're
eating what does your diet look like in
terms of what you're reading what's
you're hearing what you're smelling
what's your test what you're touching oh
man you're tasting
and each of those things for example if
we are reading the news all the time
what is reading the news generally in
today's world do maybe living in the
metropolis instead of nature right but
like we're reading negative things
generally about the news bad things that
have happened and that's gonna make us
anxious right that's gonna create a
vibration in us and we're gonna carry
that with us but if we're reading like
something peaceful or like a you know
meditation book what kind of vibration
is that going to give you same thing if
we're smelling you know the first the
first sense that's actually activated in
the human body is the sense of smell we
actually create community around our
sense of smell all the foods we cook
together all those things our nose
actually is very powerful so if we're
taking the time to smell something that
relaxes us and is good for our energy
and you know helps us feel clearer yeah
that's gonna help activate a certain
vibration in us that's gonna make us
feel better too this is a great idea to
bring some beautiful scent with you yeah
and certain scents can affect the dosha
the vet opit the kava too
so there's a whole science around that
yeah and at Polaris I am doing Ayurvedic
consultations so I help people
understand what their dosha is and how
to balance that in this environment that
we live in so it takes a hard look at
everything you're doing from the way
your poop looks and the color of it and
the shape and what's coming out to you
know what you're doing on a daily basis
your daily habits again talking about
that consistency of being in light and
so our Veda is a series of little tiny
changes that you can make on a daily
basis and incorporate into a lifestyle
routine that will help prevent and
protect you from disease and getting
sick
okay so then earth air fire water ether
and then we are some like spicy food as
fire
maybe yeah exactly there's like some
sort of maybe like meditative music is
like water or there's a lot of that
right so again what we're ingesting
through a five senses so food certain
foods have qualities that are going to
affect us so exactly what you just said
if we eat something spicy and we already
have a fiery energy it's gonna bring out
more fire but if we eat something
cooling on a hot day or when we're angry
like we decide to have a piece of
cucumber or some watermelon or something
even cilantro is the cooling herb then
that's gonna cool our whole energy
system down and balance it right and so
it's all about balance and I our Vedas
very big on understanding your own
digestion and the best indicator of how
you're digesting your food is how your
poop looks and so we can go into a lot
of that but our microbiomes going crazy
with sampling your stool yeah
understanding what's going on so and you
can tell a lot by the way you poop yeah
you know and your constipation levels
and the earth you know all of those
things so it's really about gauging and
you know all the little daily habits of
of what you're taking in with your five
senses and figuring out how to optimize
your environment for that balanced
interesting there's going to be more IRA
vetted conversation between us because I
have a lot of questions to poke into
that okay yeah and there's more sound
meditation to also play okay oh my gosh
Serena do you think we're in a
simulation yeah of course tell us why
and tell you why well other than the
media alluding to it in in several
stories all the time
I personally think that there is
something guiding us and if we can tune
into what and how we're being guided we
can actually navigate what we're
supposed to do in our best of intention
here with that intentional presence I
was talking about or we can let a demon
come out and it can be an environment
where were controlled that's what I
think yeah yeah yeah
what about you and then like I could get
into like a two-hour conversation with
you about stimulation practice what
about what's the most beautiful thing in
the world it's the most beautiful thing
in the world
oh you know I have the blessing of
having this adorable little dog named
Charlie which you got to meet Charlie I
love Charlie - I wish she was here but I
think the most beautiful thing is our
ability to relate to other creatures
like dogs and cats and use you know yeah
dolphins insects and I think it's I
think it's beautiful that you can have a
dialect and literally a conversation
energetically speaking with with a
different animal like with it
you know where you're not speaking words
have you with the tree of course yeah
yeah they grow in like families right
you can see there yeah supporting each
other through their branches and like
there's so much you can pay attention to
a nature that's around us that's like
very evident of this community it's the
best feature interesting so kind of like
yeah that that nonverbal communication
you're having with like your dog and
stuff like that yeah I think that's
really beautiful let's let's let's wrap
with a singing and
and meditating and yeah yeah let's do it
okay should we do three ohms together to
kind of end things and then I'll maybe
play one of the metal bowls to end it
yeah but sound good okay that's two
three ohms together deep inhale
Oh
Oh
shanthi shanthi
the
they will play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow what a session Wow Sooni thank you
so much for coming on to our show thank
you so much for having me I had so much
fun thank you I've never been done one
of these so I'm just excited to have
done it get got through it thank you
crushed it talking about your passion
your we'd love for everyone to check out
the links in the bio below to Serena
Malkani dot-com also our Instagram
profile and our YouTube videos go check
those out go and have more conversation
to your friends your families coworkers
online on social media about sound
meditation and Ayurveda and go and
really just get an instrument near the
bedside and do it in the morning and I
can get practising more if they use your
voice on a daily basis around you and
also thank you to all your people for
producing and greatly appreciated Ori
thank you thanks Horry and also you
don't let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on the episodes support
us all of our links are below for
simulations support the artists and
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world that you believe in check us
out patreon cryptocurrency paypal is all
down there and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in bye